you said that i could not invite dwight
because he was not part of a couple and
because we didn't have enough wine
glasses
dwight brought glasses and a person fine
whatever you want just like always
whatever you want whatever i want it's
never whatever i want it's fine when i
wanted to see stomp and you wanted to
see wicked what did we see we saw
when i said that i wanted to have kids
and you said that you wanted me to have
a vasectomy what did i do
and then oh when you said that you might
want to have kids and i wasn't so sure
who had this vasectomy reversed and then
when you said you definitely didn't want
to have kids who had to reverse back
snip snap snip snap sniff snap
i did okay you have no idea the physical
toll the three vasectomies have a person
and i bought this condo
to fill with children i'm so sorry that
i don't want to bring kids into this
screwed up world okay but look if you
want to have kids then fine you win
kid
do you
mean my life
so can we come in
dwight
i can't be there for you
i'm sorry
jim
i just
really wish there was something i could
do
michael
i can't believe you came
that's what you said
[Laughter]
best prank ever
yeah hey can i talk to you for a second
sure feel right now
so i've been meaning to tell you i want
to take you out for lunch for your last
day
oh
what do you think tomorrow lunch you and
me
okay
you're not leaving tomorrow
you're leaving today right
maybe
wow so that's it huh just
four o'clock and you are gone for good
why am i so sad
am i doing the wrong thing
absolutely not
it's just that sometimes goodbyes are a
[ __ ]
t-shirt idea goodbye stink
okay all right
so
james halpert
you started with this company
as a fine young man you know what i
think we should do
i think we should just say the goodbyes
for tomorrow at lunch
oh
okay
and then tomorrow
i can tell you
what a great boss you turned it out to
be
best boss i ever had
oh shoot
that's my cab all right all right listen
michael i i really i did text pam but i
know it's okay
just give her a hug all right
i will see you tomorrow at lunch i am
looking forward to lunch
and hearing about what a great buzz like
you got it
okay
i have a question for aaron
really
yes um
the thing i found most compelling about
the documentary was
your search for your birth mother
thank you
so my my question is um
don't you hate her i mean i would i
would just imagine that you were so
angry at her that you would hate her
maybe sometimes
but not like hate hate
more just like
mom i hate you
and then
she would say
go to your room young lady and i'd stamp
my foot and run upstairs and
i have a room which is really cool and
then we just have dinner together
but i don't know i'd have to meet her
thanks
erin
yes
oh
[Music]
oh
aaron
yeah is there a follow follow-up
question
aaron
same question what about your dad
[Applause]
fine i'll just go sit at my desk and be
quiet
sorry i annoyed you with my friendship
[Music]
and i'm also sorry
that a lot of people here
for some reason think it's funny to
steal someone's personal property and
hide it from them
here's a little news flash it's not
funny
in fact it's pretty freaking unfunny
that was an overreaction
gonna hit the break room does anybody
want anything
damn you good
yeah sure okay
hey
i want to say something
i've been trying to be more honest
lately
and i just need to say a few things i
did the coal walk
just i did it
michael you couldn't even do that
maybe i should be your boss
wow i feel really good right now
why didn't any of you come to my art
show
i invited all of you that really sucked
it's like sometimes some of you act like
i don't even exist
jim i called off my wedding because of
you
and now we're not even friends
and things are just like weird between
us and that sucks
and i miss you
you were my best friend before you went
to stamford
and i really miss you
i shouldn't have been with roy
and there were a lot of reasons to call
off my wedding
but the truth is i didn't care about any
of those reasons until i met you
and now you're with someone else
and that's fine
it's
whatever that's not what i'm
i'm not okay my feet really hurt
the thing that i'm just trying to say to
you jim
and to everyone else in the circle i
guess
is that i miss having fun with you
just you not everyone in the circle
okay i am gonna go walk in the water now
yeah
it's a good day
pam
that was amazing
but i am still looking for someone with
a sales background
oh it's white we're so close
just buy us a few more minutes
well they just called me in for an
update so i'll call you right back
okay okay great
now
hey dwight uh
send in the subs
oh
you